hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge wie schmeckt und heute machen wir
den caritas habitat ja ja ich bin ein
die erste frage die ich mir gestellt
habe woraus besteht dieser tabu tor erst
gedachten can take aber pancakes in so
babbel ich weiß gar nicht danach die
flächen keks aber ein krieg sich ja
nicht so groß wie dieser teletubbies ich
schätze mal ein dass der teletubbies so
groß weil ich glaube dass einfach
menschen hinter diesen täter bestecken
und menschen sind ja so groß wie wir die
ein mensch und deswegen die halten den
halt so also ich glaube einfach dass der
so groß ist meine letzte idee war
lebkuchen und ich glaube lebt kommt ihm
wirklich am nächsten aber wie immer
werde ich natürlich das leben rezept
verändern
ja also kurz gesagt ich mach
lebkuchengewürz der melanie fischer
fischer soll jetzt ein spiel trinken für
unsere teams brauchen wir auf jeden fall
margarine flüssigen honig ein bisschen
kakaobaum ein bisschen kaka und ganz
viel zucker und wir brauchen ein ei ich
hab so teuer gekauft wo man sogar eine
dankeskarte drin bekommen denn mit dem
kauf dieser eier unterstützen sie die
aufzucht von männlichen lege küken ganz
ehrlich die waren gar nicht viel teurer
als die andern da braucht ihr auf jeden
fall was eure katzen angebissen haben
das ist pflicht und natürlich brauchen
wir backpulver wisst ihr was mich auch
noch gefragt habe wenn ich lebkuchen
ohne lebkuchengewürz mache ist es dann
am ende honigkuchen ich kann es jetzt
auch google aber es ist eine kleine
quizfrage für euch fed honig zucker und
gewürze unter rühren erhitzen bis sich
der zucker verbundes ist voll
anstrengung
60 59 mit einem löffel kommt mein
kindergarten suppenkoch geil und in der
zeit in der das lustig wird machen wir
schon mal die mischung ein gestrichener
teelöffel backpulver 250 gramm mehl das
haben ja gar nicht die teletubbies
gemacht das hat er die kelle david hohs
maschine beim backen musst du dich
schmutzig machen sonst hast du nicht
richtig gepackt
es gibt nichts was besser riecht als
kakaopulver wir machen nur zwei
teelöffel und jetzt müsst ihr die
trockene masse verrühren
das klappt schon ganz gut ich bin so
eine richtige haus drauf meint sogar ist
jetzt aufgelöst wie zucker flüssigkeit
muss jetzt abkühlt wusstet ihr
eigentlich dass die hasen wie bei
teletubbies öfter mal sieht wie sein
grosser hasen waren kostüme von den
teletubbies war nämlich auch richtig
groß und das wir mussten sie halt im
verhältnis noch miteinander pass es
waren riesen mutanten h und der lilie
teletubbie winky stand so in der kritik
weil eine rote handtasche hatte und nie
lava und so ein dreieck geformte antenne
hatte also die leute dachten damals das
ist halt so eine homosexuelle anspielung
ist das halt damit homosexualität ja
unterstützt abgekühlt und da muss jetzt
noch eine rein und schnell rühren sie
doch nett aus jetzt eben unser mehl und
zucker masse verrühren alles miteinander
ich glaube so soll es aussehen
ich lebe ist es keine gute idee gewesen
schneebesen keine gute idee gewesen die
leute da draußen
das ist jetzt unser glatter teig und er
soll jetzt an einem kühlen ort zwei
stunden rühren ruhen nicht rühren würde
ich nicht vom fleck
oh wir drauf und uplink im schrank winke
winke tag bis in zwei stunden nur zwölf
stunden wandel vom feld könntest ihr ein
ganzes jahr lang jeden tag eine
teletubbie folgen gucken denn es gibt
61 folgen und während unser teig sich
jetzt zwei stunden ausruht gehe ich zwei
folgen walking dead gucken denn ich
brauche wieder etwas anderes als
teletubbies so viel zombies so unser
teig ist jetzt komplett ausgeruht seht
ihr so ausgeruht jetzt schon mal
aufgefallen dass tipps hier am
dunkelsten von 1 ist und po am herzen
das liegt daran dass tipps sie schwarz
sein sollte und wo sollte chinesisch
seien aber so ganz haben die sich auch
nicht getraut
das ist eine fläche auf der das
ausrollen werden ließ lux fantastic es
riecht einfach nur nach honig und jetzt
müssen wir nur noch einen runden kreis
ausschneiden das ist so groß wie ein
teletubbie tust ja so groß ist ungefähr
das jetzt heißen wir unseren backofen
auf 150 grad umluft hier ist er unter
tourismus jetzt für zwölf bis 15 minuten
in den backofen was habe ich denn hier
einen neuen fun fact they kies
schauspieler war eigentlich ein
balletttänzer vielleicht sollten wir die
teletubbies maschine anwerfen damit es
schneller geht teletubbies maschine los
geht's
caritas natürlich könnte man jetzt
selber zuckerguss machen oder man kauft
einfach fertigen ich weiß es auf dem
tapet es wahrscheinlich keinen zugang es
gab aber gesehen wenn wir hier machen
wen ich habe vor dem backen schon ein
gesicht rein gemacht und das finde ich
jetzt noch mit circus henry 1 august
fertig schön dass ihr jetzt mag sein
da kannst du richtig viel sprechen und
delta vitus ist fertig findet er ist mir
sehr gut gelungen
ich erkenne kaum ein unterschied und er
ist auch so dick und so groß wie ein
trabi tus und jetzt stellen wir uns der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
ta wie toaster information das ist jetzt
hier nicht einfach ein klassischer lebt
hungern oder scannen gewürzt drin ich
habe weniger grau reingemacht also das
ist ein richtiger cavit ok schmeckt
richtig gut vor allem weil zeit nach
honig schmeckt und nicht nach irgendwie
lebkuchen jetzt ohne scheiß der schmeckt
genauso wie der tabus aussieht also
genau so stellt man sich den geschmack
vor wenn euch noch ein gericht von einer
serie oder im film einfällt dann
schreibt mir es in die kommentare und
vielleicht koche ich es nächste mal nach
ach ja und ich habe noch ein penis
gebacken
ich hoffe wirklich hat die folge
gefallen und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste mal bis dann
wir hoffen euch hat das video gefallen
wenn ja dann abonniert doch den kanal
bis dann
nun gibt und euren abgetrennten daumen
nach oben